at least ah but I want to go to rally
cuz I think it is like the funniest show
that you'll ever see oh the but I've
I've fully accepted it America's over
and that we're like it's done we're on
the decline I'm like no you don't think
so no what what what cause I don't know
yeah
college football still [ __ ] rules so
yeah that's a good we got that going for
yeah that's a good been to a game lately
no I should you should go to that yeah
can get some I just think the problems
are too deep that if they do get solved
it'll be some miracle and it's like I've
I'm not personally invested in like what
it is what's gonna happen is gonna
happen we got a lot of you know we got
amazing coming a I the the reason the
truck like Trump is like I want Logan
Paul because here's the thing I like
Logan Paul I met Logan Paul didn't steal
Vons podcast
do you remember Logan Paul with the
whole thing in the suicide forest loved
it yeah well I didn't realize why people
get that angry at him but he you know he
was that like cancelled he was you know
lost endorsements he was being you know
attacked everybody online celebrities
people that were his friends and I
talked to him about that he goes people
I knew that where my friends were
turning on me and he goes I know I made
a mistake and I did a stupid thing but
he goes the vitriol hatred that was
coming at me from people that I was
friendly with and that I knew was wild
well it's also with that one it's also
like people like me I had never watched
any of his stuff until I watched that
episode where he was in Japan yeah
dressed as a Pokemon throw him pokeballs
at random Asian people right yeah then
we were watching that you like Jesus
Christ yeah it's a little much he fully
admits that he was wiling it was a
little while it was why this is why I
want him to be present I went to his
house to do a podcast he lives like the
kid from blank check he's just got
sneakers and Ferraris strewn around the
yard you know they've got a film crew
filming him him and his brother just
walk around is like it's like Netflix
you know it it's terrifying and he said
to me he said to me and he said to music
you know what in in ten years if I'm
bored I will run for president
I had this really dark thought not only
would he do it but that he might win and
then I had even the darker thought I
went and he might not be that bad he
actually might be pretty good at it and
should I get involved now to start
trying to groom him if to be the press
should I be Logan Paul Steve Bannon yes
yes speak and here's why I'm able to do
it I've given up on the idea that it's
all gonna be okay like I think I've
embraced what the stage of the empire
were in and I think Logan Paul is a
fitting present for that stage of the
Empire Nero I think he's a fitting Nero
and I want to help him get there because
he had a horse and saying this is a
highly disciplined guy he's high fans
yes yes no I mean he's well put together
ABS I think I think he could do it
here's the other thing I think you have
all these youtube stars they're all in
in in in in 15 years 20 years they're
all gonna be multi millionaires have
huge fan bases and no skills so I think
that's where that's the pool of people
that you're gonna get your politicians
from they're gonna come from YouTube
because that's you know they just
they're only provable skill is like
amassing these large following hey guys
a lot of minds their skill hey guys hey
guys just garbage but that's what that's
what's gonna win the presidency show hey
guys are you feeling good like I think
things are gonna get so bad we're like
these guys are just gonna be up like
because I think the fireside chat will
be like a YouTube where they just get on
in they go
hey guys you feeling good today I was
feeling bad yesterday but today I'm
feeling a little better as a makeup
tutorial and I hope you are too I think
that's where we're going and then
they're gonna be like now watch me eat
the cereal very slowly you know it's
it's so I that's why I'm actually trying
to investigate what I would have to do
to - I think you're doing the right
thing right now getting in front of this
thing let him know I'm letting him know
who
who you think of her voice well whatever
no I don't Paul Paul ticket Paul Paul I
don't know I I think we we're gonna
gotta go with a woman we gotta balance
out to straight whiteness of it all you
get wove icky we need one of them
yeah we'll Vic your bed baby we need one
of that baby baby she got just she just
got smacked up yeah one by one so over
that was wove it Philly I think sounds
feel they both look like Kensington to
me North Philly where can you look up
Bobby we're bad babies from please and
start producing this goddamn show and
wove ik can we get out bad baby and wove
icky where they're from Thank You Bobby
I know when Rogen's in here everybody
pays attention when I come in everybody
likes to go to sleep I'd a look like
either Long Island or Philly it does
yeah well they're their city where the
opioid crisis is yeah it's ravaged
ravaged ravaged the area what do we got
Bobby what do we got Robert Robert
Hutchins bad bad babies from Florida
yeah do it that's it
that'll do it and what about whoa Vicky
I think she's from the desert now big
baby has some catchy songs what about
Wolvie now little Zen follows me on
Twitter you know Lulu's an
little Zen yeah yeah yeah I'm very happy
now Sam's a decent candidate I Janice
you're absolutely right about it's gonna
be a good cabinet it's gonna be good I
think the Chinese are I'm not there's no
part of me that's kidding about this I
want everyone to know that there's no
part of me that's kidding about trying
to put Logan Paul in the White House
that's a good ticket I I don't think
he'd be that bad where is well Vicky
from Robert she's from Atlanta Georgia
whoa Vicky if she good is woven yeah
that's good that's what you want for
those red states you want to get a
someone from Georgia you need somebody
from Georgia in there that's good Logan
Paul whoa Vicky